hey 42 here the visual tail light you
see trailing from a comet has nothing to
do with its direction of travel it's
actually because solar winds push on its
surrounding gases so that it is always
pointing away from the Sun welcome to
RIF a traffic jam once lasted for more
than ten days with cars only moving 0.6
miles per day if you could convert the
mass in a 1 kilogram bag of sugar into
energy it would be enough to drive a car
non-stop for 100,000 years people who
feel lonely tend to wake up more
frequently throughout the night while
sleeping Monty Python's film The Life of
Brian was marketed in Sweden as the film
that was so funny it was banned in
Norway wooly mammoths were still around
when the Egyptian pyramids were being
built an Olympic rower named Henry
Pierce once won a race even though he
stopped along the way to let some dogs
pass by everyone has a unique smell
except for identical twins asking
someone where are you is a recent
phenomena before we had mobile phones
the only way we could talk to people is
if we already knew where they were if
you touch your tongue whilst yawning it
can stop the York if you start with one
penny and doubled your money every day
it would only take 27 days to become a
millionaire in the entire state of Ohio
in 1895 there were only two cars on the
road and they crashed into each other
dr. Seuss wrote green eggs and ham to
win a bet against his publisher who
fought that he could not complete a book
using only 50 words if you were to
remove all the empty space from the
atoms that make up every human on earth
the entire world population could fit
inside and
or in 1367 King Charles five of France
explicitly ban the wearing of shoes
shaped like penises slots sometimes
mistakenly grabbed their own arm instead
of a tree branch which can lead to a
fatal fall thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2
[Music]
you